good morning to all
participants of the festival of
philosophy since the founding of
the european union we have worked to
build
societies based on shared values
related to human rights equality
and non-discrimination
we have since made
significant progress but much remains  to
do in the fight against discrimination and
in the pum promote equality
and inclusion of lgbt people the cu
in the european union
for this reason the
european commission has adopted its first
strategy for lgbt equality the q in
2020 in the wider framework
lgbt iq equality is a
strategy that will help us build
a union where people in all
their diversity are equal in the sense of
equal rights
where they can be themselves without
risk of discrimination exclusion or
violence
to realize this vision is the
lgbt strategy that presents the actions
and objects  therein key of the commission
for the next five years around
four pillars
fight discrimination
increase security
build inclusive societies
lead the call for lgbt rights
yucumo around the world but
concretely how this strategy
will help change things it is better
let me give some examples  many
member states currently lack
laws to punish hate crimes and
discrimination as well as those related
to hate speech against
lgbt people q
the strategy announces the initiative to
extend the
european union's list of crimes to cover precisely
hate crimes and hate speech
even when targeting
lgbt people q also due to
current legal differences between
member states rainbow families
continue to struggle to have
their family ties recognized
when traveling between states
within the european union
despite these differences ne
national legislations
the commission will push for
mutual recognition of
family relationships in the european union as
stated by the president in her
state of the union address
if you are a parent in a country you are a
parent in each country to achieve
the objectives of the strategy the
commission will use  all
tools at your disposal
targeted actions will be
combined with more mainstreaming
of equality lgbt people q like
all other groups are not a
homogenous group
reason why intersectionality ta will be
used as a cross-cutting principle
when implementing the strategy
EU ru's actions to
promote youku lgbt equality
must be matched by
sustained efforts at all levels why
more we call
for yokoo lgbt equality strategy
in all 27 european union member states
what the european union stands for
and i am convinced that together
we will build a lgbt the cool
fridzon thanks for your attention
and good thoughts